merci donc sous les 2 juste une dernière
information aujourd'hui lundi 15 octobre
versailles devait jouer elle son grand
oral pour accueillir l la cité de la
gastronomie
ce sera dans les locaux de l'ancienne
poste du côté de donc de versailles vous
envoyer les images 7 heures à les
repousser plus tard dans la semaine en
raison d'une mauvaise interprétation de
la commission sur le financement du
dossier pour autant versailles confirme
reste est candidate dans ce dossier
olivier de la faire et qui porte ce
dossier pour le conseil général nous a
confirmé que versailles reste est
candidate même si certains de nos
confrères ont annoncé que versailles
avait retiré son dossier plus
d'explications dans les prochains jours
c'est la fin de cette édition du 7 8
prochaines diffusions 19h 22h30 et
minuit je vous retrouve demain nous
parlons notamment de la réforme de
l'éducation au vaste chantier excellente
soirée